ok t'es prêt oh merde ouais ouais ouais
voilà ça vient ok ok je suis prêt
allons tous au tribunal allez merci Boyet les
gars vous ne me connaissez pas et rejoignez moi
vous regardez vous
wow on est défoncé c'était [ __ ]  gel
lisse écoutez j'ai de grandes nouvelles à
vous dire oh ouais qu'est-ce que
Tammy gagne et je vais avoir un bébé -
c'est [ __ ] de génial félicitations
ma chérie comment allez-vous les gars c'est la chose
que nous devons trouver un donneur de sperme que nous pouvons
obtenir beaucoup  d'ennuis pouvez-vous penser à
quelqu'un de mieux que lui serait un
[ __ ] de bébé adorable Je baise Brady
le plus grand athlète du pays
donnons ma branlette dans ce
gobelet en plastique rouge que vous n'avez pas fumé depuis deux
jours entiers  Je t'ai dit que je suis propre, d'
accord, ton bébé ira bien,
je suis désolé, je ne veux tout simplement pas de
quelque chose que j'ai nourri avec une
fourche  un morceau de merde
peut-être plus comme un marteau ou une orange
c'est juste un mot celui de mes ancêtres  minute
tu n'es pas l'Afrique tu veux une rivière pour
laver tes vêtements bon sang accroche
toi oui tu sais que tu te fais baiser
par Thomas Jefferson Wow tu
donnes vie à l'histoire Johnny qu'est ce qu'on va faire
on va prendre un avocat et on  Je poursuivrai le
[ __ ] de gouvernement, ces droits civiques
regardent sa tête, ça vous dérange, j'ai demandé au vieux,
vous n'êtes pas nous six, ce que vous savez, je
ne veux tout simplement pas que mon avocat chante des
chansons gelées pendant les plaidoiries d'ouverture, nous
apprécions vraiment votre temps, mais je pense
quoi  nous allons probablement
nous asseoir et comprendre que je vais tirer
complètement ouais nous avons vraiment l'impression que vous
avez beaucoup à offrir aux migraines Je
vais avoir une énorme migraine sur le
parking dans environ 20 minutes
là-bas  Ce serait spécial, mais qu'est-ce qui définit une
personne qui contribue à l'
exercice de la société, puis-je utiliser votre ordinateur portable
ouais allez-y, [ __ ], qu'est-ce qui se
passe, il y a tellement de porno que je
voulais en effacer une partie,
regardez le  organisation ici dans le
sens des aiguilles d'une montre  rimjob sage parfois
tu aimes voir la langue aller dans l'autre
sens
poussins avec des [ __ ] oh nous pourrions attraper une
maladie d'accord j'ai besoin d'aide il n'y a pas de
poussins avec des [ __ ] Johnny seulement des mecs avec des
seins